en pleine pandémie de comics 19
c'est un autre virus qui s'est répandu
en colombie celui de la contestation
depuis le 28 avril et la mobilisation
contre le projet de réforme fiscale
porté par le gouvernement le pays
connaît sans discontinuer de nouvelles
manifestations syndicat étudiant
indigènes et défenseurs de
l'environnement continue à battre le
pavé malgré le retrait du projet de loi
dans le viseur des manifestants une
amélioration des politiques de santé
d'éducation de sécurité et une
dénonciation des violences policières
en tant que maire en tant que femme en
tant que soeur en tant que fille nous
disons que nous n'avons pas donné
naissance pour la guerre nous n'avons
pas donné naissance pour que nos fils et
nos filles ou nous mêmes
soyons assassiné pour avoir protesté
pour avoir exercé nos droits pour avoir
exigé la liberté l'autonomie une vie
digne
une bonne gouvernance nous soutenons
tous les jeunes qui sortent pour
manifester tous les jeunes qui sont
traités comme des hooligans
parce que je suis jeune et je sors pour
manifester et ils nous traitent comme
des vandales
alors que ce n'est pas le cas un
mouvement de protestation qui s'est donc
portée à la violente réaction des forces
de l'ordre
le bilan est lourd plus d'une vingtaine
de personnes ont été tuées et quelques
centaines d'autres blessés une
répression qui a renforcé la
contestation entre le président ivan
bouquet dont la popularité est en berne
ce dernier a appelé à la levée des
barrages qui parsèment le pays et au
dialogue à tous les espaces sont ouverts
ici pour construire pourparlers pour
construire des solutions pour le pays
comme nous l'avons toujours fait mais la
voix de chacun doit être clair pour
rejeter les blocages qui constitue
également une violation des droits de
l'homme et des citoyens
fort d'une grande diaspora
les colombiens se sont mobiles
lisez un peu partout dans le monde quand
en espagne aux etats-unis ou encore en
france une mobilisation internationale
qui a poussé les nations unies l'union
européenne ou encore les états unis a
condamné les agissements de la police en
colombie un isolement diplomatique qui
fragilise encore plus la position du
président du quai à un an de la
prochaine élection présidentielle